[Music]
you
[Music]
for casein I sat there are two competing
obsessions in his life YouTube videos
and Shake Shack so far our season finale
we knew we had to roll out the burger
show red carpet which is why we brought
him to the exclusive Shake Shack
innovation kitchen for the ultimate
bucket list burger experience to
taste-test special limited edition
burgers and crown a winner
[Music]
yeah okay see what's up brother so good
to finally meet you no thanks for being
on the show I'm a fan of the show I'm a
huge fan of your restaurant youtuber
vlogger filmmaker extraordinaire I'm so
excited for this there's a Shake Shack
across the street from my bedroom and
the green flows into my bedroom like
this and I am on like I'd say 50 to 60%
of my caloric intake is Shake Shack
amazing but I you know I would take your
Shake Shack over almost any fast food I
like a fat burger okay
I like me now oh dude yes last time
you're on first few feasts he's tapping
out part of this like two people quit
sometimes Shaun you did my boy dirty
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing not clear
girl not cool but today this is kind of
like karmic reward I'm ready right this
is all about pleasure no pain this is
kind of like you know the editing room
right this is where like new ideas get
tested and then become burgers to be
sold all over the world so what we get
to try today is never these are like
unreleased yes no these are like limited
edition runs this is like you know
waiting for a shoe at supreme without
having to be in line and like all the
hype beasts are just like yo yes guys
aren't in those hi peeps like yo let me
get a bite of that sneakers we're two
luckiest bastards in the world right now
so ready right this is the plug Mark
Rosati he's a culinary genius behind
shake Shack's burgers and and what do
you have for us today so what this is is
a special burger we created chef from
Japan it's Iowa Hasegawa he has a
two-star Michelin restaurant and he's
restaurant number 17 on the world's 50
best list right now what he created here
is a plain burger double-smoked bacon a
special mix up of his house-made red
miso paste Arshak sauce and
some pickled cucumbers laid him out on
top like fish skin he's a very cool guys
a very fun guy to the point that he has
his own figurine dude so I'm gonna leave
that here as you gentlemen enjoy the
burger I feel like I'm being judged
let's do this yeah Cheers
why don't they service at every
restaurant exactly this thing is
fantastic I'm a little bit of a like a
Philistine when it comes to fine
culinary right but typically I like
that's just a straight burger because I
find that when the burgers are too much
[ __ ] on them or whatever you don't taste
the burger all right I agree but this
just feels like it's like elevating it
making the burger burger better I feel
like the sauce is like a an Asian
Steakhouse sauce where it's like it kind
of elevates the beef flavor you could
tell a fine mind put this burger
together for people like me uninformed
consumers I would probably be
intimidated and not know to order this
if I saw it on the menu like what it was
being pitched to us yeah I'll just talk
no it makes sense or any of those words
are double smoked a special mix of our
shots awesome eating you're like [ __ ]
that's amazing yeah you have to like
open your eyes a little bit where it's
like if I'm trying to understand the
chef in his culture he nailed it
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I could never make a
burger like that
I make food that tastes like this so I
watch a bunch of your videos all right
now I want to tell a story and what
admire most is that you call YouTube
like a democratic platform
I feel like burgers are a democratic
food but in like this crazy world people
are making highbrow lowbrow situations
where there's like a 300 dollar burger
or chicken wings that are laced with
gold leaf like in your world in your
mind is there room for stuff like that I
think that they're the kind of a good
parallel it's kind of a good analogy cuz
you got like the biggest youtuber in the
world like Nighy 83 million subscribers
and he's just a camera that's filming
himself there's one camera that he's
talking to you know
thinking complicated about what he's
doing sometimes a 1970s burger is better
than like the $80 wag you gigantic
burped you just don't want I could agree
more nothing anymore than seeing a
colleague fall into that trap you know
who you are that was intimidating when I
said I know who you are I know who you
are so the next one I have for you is
for Chef Massimo Bottura we're going to
Italy on this one here and he has
restaurant Osteria francescana and
Modena number one restaurant on the
world's 50 best list three Michelin
stars and we created a burger together
called the Amelia and what do you want
to do is celebrate everything that's
great about us region so with the Patti
we have cooked akeno's sausage in
parmesan ground into the meat smashing
griddle on the bottom is balsamic
mayonnaise using the chef's own balsamic
and on top to cut through all that
richness salsa verde we actually serve
this twice once in New York City for one
day and once in London for one day it
was absolutely madness where happens
when you serve it for one day like
people know it's coming and they wait
for it they do we've actually been very
fortunate where every time we've done
one of these we actually see some of the
same people show up depending on what
the city is first in line some get there
as early as 5:00 a.m. say I got to see
what that's like Shake Shack is creating
like a whole hype beast food situation
yeah mm-hmm just use number one the
number one shop on Pellegrino's list for
a goddamn reason so where is that
what's the crispiest they put cheese in
the meat before they yeah coach Dino
sausage beef and Parmesan cheese in
patty then they smash it so the cheese
melts and then creates like a crisp and
that's why it's all brown and crunchy
around this yeah this is getting into
the mind of a Michelin star chef it's
soft sweet clean and refreshing with the
salsa verde crunchy umami with the meat
and the cheese and then like this nice
creamy acidic balsamic mayo the den
burger felt like it was like a lighter
it was like almost a sweeter almost more
like
freshing very refreshing yeah but this
one feels like the like the flavors in
it have more cohesion antonius harmony
is the word oh yes
it's like a [ __ ] that's how an opera
in a [ __ ] burger man no this is the
Italian and opera of burgers in the
world in the kingdom of YouTube there's
so many like food subcultures
my favorite genre sub-genre of food
shows on YouTube is there's this guy
7-elevens in Japan's are like a like a
culinary cacophony of food choices and
they're amazing and there's a guy who
goes in there and does like brunch in a
7-eleven what and he just tries
everything inside of a settlement he
eats it while he's in there in the zone
I don't think he has permission to do it
but he just does it and then that would
never exist could you imagine pitching
that to like food well yeah the tiny
food people have you seen that where
they make like the tinier and they're
like a little hamster come at me right
what precipitates in someone's mind that
come up with making a perfect taco to
feed to a hamster exactly but I can't
stop watching it that's fascinating
scribe so what we have here is a burger
that we've actually created for our Los
Angeles shake Shack's
it's something that you can get all the
time but only in Los Angeles we're
really excited about this it's called
the roadside double inspired by all
those old burger shacks that have been
around since the 50s here what it is is
a double swiss burger and then we add a
little bit of bacon and beard simmered
onions we cook those in our own Shack
maestro beer then the last touch is a
little Dijon mustard it's actually
inspired by the iconic sandwich of La
the French dish - yeah so it's kind of
our loose interpretation of it but then
ultimately other day just a good
old-fashioned Shake Shack burger your
biceps tired from having to hold heavy
ass burger you know it's a labor of love
same size is my head
hmm this is like punching in the face
flavor mm-hmm right
I just mean coming yeah there's the
bitterness from the beer onions and then
the mustard just like yeah yeah and then
if that's not enough you've got like two
patties look at it from here and coming
from here the two patties changed the
dynamic of the entire bird doesn't
Abunda burger the ratio ratio down
yeah the ratio is off like this bun is
made for one patty I think because it's
so thin and squishy let me tell you what
I'm thankful for Kelly I'm thankful for
that it doesn't have avocado because I
feel like Ellie has a crazy rap don't
have a have to put you don't have to put
avocado zhan everything man you don't
and it's definitely not a California
thing is on an LA thing I grew up there
I didn't put avocados on everything I
was a kid we used to go to this place in
Pico called guacamole
okay and their burgers had walking it so
you know that's always a highlight why
not right and I'm so thank you for not
putting avocados on this yeah we both
like avocados right avocados are great
sure they don't belong in every not on
everything I'm a burger traditionalist
this steps out salad outside the realm
of what I would classify as a burger
this is like a whole nother [ __ ]
monster right here
so we've traveled to Japan we've
traveled to Italy cruise down La of the
three burgers hmm which one's your
favorite this might surprise you I think
the first one I think the Japanese I why
okay I've never tasted a burger like
that before
yeah that was a complete I've never
tasted a burger like that hose on mine
the second one the Italian one was
extraordinary absolutely extraordinary
but there was something about there like
the cleanest the the the levity that
pickled cucumbers Lent that first one I
know I hyped up the VIP experience okay
where does this rank this in your view
this is the top huh this is the tie I
didn't do bad look it's one thing when
you show up it like a fancy ass
restaurant where there's like the guy
that like walks your wife to this seat
and super uncoupling some idea napkin in
your lap oh yeah don't get so close yeah
this is behind the scenes baby Shake
Shack Oh
but get we had like we had the
Burgermeister of Shake Shack making us
his favorite recipes sliding it over
huge I appreciate you coming by I
appreciate you spending our season
finale thank you for having you know I'm
honored to have you see at the
restaurant I'll see you on the Internet
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up burger world's haven't caught
a lot of the burgers show smash that
like button hit that subscribe button if
not for me for the segue